i mean i mean
ultimate couples goals right here for
real it's a boy for nicki minaj and
kenneth petty
earlier this month e.t confirmed the
lovebirds welcomed their first child
together back in september
i'm very excited about that and ever
since fans have been patiently waiting
to find out if it's a girl or a boy
yes well the rapper confirmed that it's
a little boy on thursday
when she shared a series of pics on
instagram showcasing some of the cards
her famous friends have sent
yeah famous friends like beyonce kim
kardashian and kanye west
in the caption the 37 year old thanked
her pals adding quote
i am so grateful and in love with my son
madly in love
my favorite little boy in the whole wide
world
yep nikki has a son all these [ __ ] is
my sons
this is crazy but can we take a beat to
talk about all those cards
queen bee wrote welcome to motherhood
god bless you
and your family and kim and kanye sent
congrats
adding we love you oh thank you
supermodel winnie harlow wrote baby barb
on board before
sending her well wishes so did nikki's
tusa collaborator carol gee
[Music]
nikki and her man tied the knot last
october and she opened up about their
marriage during an appearance on lil
wayne's apple music series
young money radio over the summer i
didn't think it would be as
refreshing and calming as it is but it
kind of
you know well and you know
even if you're not married just when you
have somebody that's that
is feels like your soulmate or is very
understanding and understands you
yeah it just makes you feel like you're
on top of the world you know
nikki has been super vocal about her
desire to be a mom over the years
yes absolutely and i'll wear that title
proudly too
telling complex magazine in 2012 that
she wanted to be married with kids
before
2022. quote in 2022 i'll definitely be
married and i'll definitely have my two
children
okay i might have three nicki added that
she wanted quote at least one boy
but didn't think she really needed a
daughter you talk about the family like
how hard are we practicing right now not
to put you on the spot
we practiced you practice we practice
all the time
like i'm just you know with your time
[Music]
tonight